hello khan academy students this is
brandi chastain
former u.s women's national team member
olympic gold medalist and world cup
champion
and i'm here to say to you that
what you're doing is not easy trying to
learn
in an adverse environment to be a
champion
takes a lot of determination desire
resiliency it takes a lot of falling
down and getting back up
and i want you to know that anything
that is worthwhile
is worth fighting for is worth getting
dirty
it's worth getting a couple scrapes and
if it were easy everybody would be doing
it and it wouldn't be a big deal
but what you're doing is a big deal
you're challenging yourselves
to learn like champions and to be a
champion takes
time it's a process it's not always
going to be smooth
and most of the time success isn't this
upward ascension
straight line to gold medals
so remember that what you're doing uh
is is really a life's work and a life's
journey and
when you get to be my age you'll
understand that maybe a little bit more
but you can look back and say
i stuck with it uh it wasn't easy
sometimes i wanted to give up i know
that along my
journey to playing in the olympics and
being on the world cup team
and scoring that final penalty kick goal
where i got to
do a little celebrating
it was it wasn't easy i was
on the team cut from the team i made the
team in a different position which i'd
never played before
and when that was presented to me i i
had a choice
did i want to be on the team and try to
make a contribution to a positive
outcome or was i more prideful and say
no that's not my position i want to play
my position
and i realized that being on the team
and having a chance to get into the game
was really what i wanted so i want you
to remember that when things get tough
you got this you got to remember
you are talented you're smart
we all have a competitor inside of us
and you have to be willing to allow it
to come out
and don't settle never settle
becoming a gold medalist is definitely
not about settling and you in 2021
will be champions so i'm going to
uh hopefully give you your first gold
medal ever
so if you bow your head here comes the
gold medal
there it is you are now on team brandy
and we are strong and we are resilient
and we get the job done
so all the best to you in 2021 hopefully
at some point we'll meet
on a soccer field or somewhere else near
you take care